okay I've got to talk about something
that I think some people aren't going to
like you know that on this show there
are no sacred cows right this is a
left-wing progressive show so a lot of
the criticisms are of right-wing ideas
and of right-wing people but there's no
short there's no short fall there's no
shortage of misguided left-wing ideas
and left-wing people and I call them out
I don't believe in tribalism that says
even if there are people on the Left who
are toxic or have bad ideas you can't
criticize them because they're part of
the same movement the same tribe the
same left-wing so last week we got a
live call as you know Pat we don't
screen live calls for topics people can
ask anything they want and a caller said
David what do you think about Jimmy Dore
who's now going to battle against Sam
cedar or Bernie aoc Andrew Gilliam
Gilliam I don't even know how he says
his last name and I gave my opinion I
gave my opinion as I always do which was
to say in this case that I think Jimmy
Dore has become totally toxic I think
he's a useful idiot and a tool of really
bad movements and I got a ton of angry
emails and dislikes and even a handful
of people who had paid subscriptions to
the show who canceled them this is
really a concern it's a concern for me
but it's a concern for the left here's
an example email okay this is from
former member Jacqueline who said David
it's very disappointing that you have
opted to do an on-air attack to do on
air attacks on Jimmy Dore quote
completely toxic useful idiot and
dum-dum left were the choice words by
extension you are referring to his
audience as well which happens to
overlap with your audience sadly I was
foolish enough to pay the annual fee for
my Pakman membership which was valid
till next dot I still canceled anyway
you can consider this hatred mail if you
so choose but that's not what it is by
having segments attacking other
progressives who aren't lockstep with
your views you are the one being toxic
this is one of a handful of people who
wrote me stuff like this and canceled
memberships so first of all just
consider the irony that they say I'm
being toxic by attacking a progressive
who's not in lockstep with my views by
canceling their memberships because I
think door is toxic they are attacking
me financially for not being in lockstep
with their views it
sort of the same thing this is really
important okay don't miss the irony of
that but more importantly the left can't
be like this
okay there are bad ideas on the left and
right there are bad faith actors on the
left and right there are way more on the
right and we mostly focus on the ones on
the right but consider the opposite when
I get a call that says David what do you
think about the direction Jimmy Dore has
gone in my alternative instead of giving
you my honest opinion is to lie and say
he's doing great work would the audience
want me to lie and just say something
like that because of tribalism or so
that I don't anger certain people in the
audience I can't imagine that that's
what the audience wants and if the idea
is that I need to turn the show not into
what I genuinely think but instead into
what the leftist group think has
determined is better for quote the
movement that is a tribalistic disaster
so assuming you don't want me to lie to
you basically people who canceled
because I gave my honest opinion about
Jimmy are saying they're cancelling
because I have the wrong opinion and I
think that that's really dangerous
because as I've said before no two
people are going to agree on everything
ever right and if independent media is
going to survive and thrive which I
believe it needs to do okay
it can't depend on the financial support
that exists only up until there's a
disagreement on one issue right of
course people can choose to support me
or not support me for any reason right
or any other show for that matter but
this is why the right is succeeding in
so many ways they have made a commitment
where they say let's support people who
are basically on our side they might be
anti-gay but if there's a pro-gay rights
Republican who's mostly on their side
and helps their movement they support
that person they are anti-abortion but
if there's a pro-choice conservative
that's generally furthering I don't know
there's small government views or
they're low tax views or whatever they
support that person if this is how the
left is going to sit decide who we
support we're going to fail
okay and by the way if we apply the no
support if they say one wrong thing idea
what about all the people who were
supporting Jimmy Dore despite the fact
that he did at one point push seth rich
conspiracy theories if you don't buy
that stuff and i think most people in my
audience do not
wouldn't that be disqualifying of your
support for jimmy right so the main
point is let's not allow ourselves to be
ripped apart in this way and we can't do
this type of tribalism this type of
tribalism is going to destroy the
movement from the inside out if you
really think the problem is only
progressives making honest critiques of
other progressives when they feel
they're warranted and making critiques
of the right when those are warranted
that is not actually the problem and we
really need to think hard about what it
is that we're saying when you say i'm
pulling my support because i disagree
with you about this issue or that issue
or think that it should be off-limits to
criticize other progressive media i want
to hear from you about this there is a
just blockbuster bombshell new story
that we must talk about and i want to
kind of set this up for you by telling
you what this is not about we have trump
russia going on with a special
prosecutor robert muller put that aside
for now we have this abortive attempted
confirmation of donald trump Supreme
Court pick Brett Kavanaugh an alleged
serial sex assault er this is not that
story we have which we'll talk about a
little bit later on in the program this
not really new trade deal called the
u.s. MCA put that aside for now put
basically every scandal and every failed
promise aside that we have seen from and
by the Trump administration for now
because we have something totally new
that's going on this is a new state tax
investigation that has started as a
result of massive massive allegations of
fraud against Donald Trump and his
family in a just extraordinarily
detailed and thoroughly researched New
York Times special investigator
so here's what's going on New York Times
yesterday has published a to call it
lengthy is an understatement to call it
extensive as an understatement
investigation which exposes that Trump
and his family have committed quote
instances of outright fraud that is a
direct phrase from the investigation
meant to transfer millions upon millions
of dollars from Trump's father Fred
Trump to his kids without paying the
taxes that one is supposed to pay in
addition to just the claims made by the
New York Times New York state tax
officials have said we are now looking
into this there is a confirmed state tax
state-level tax investigation into what
the allegations are from the New York
Times yet another one of Donald Trump's
lawyers this is one I hadn't previously
heard of his name is Charles harder
apparently that's his real name
he obviously denied that Donald Trump
has done anything wrong has committed
any fraud no wrongdoing whatsoever
according to councilor harder the
mechanisms used here according to the
investigation to move this money around
in a way that it would not be subject to
the taxes that would normally be
prescribed by law include number one
improper tax deductions number two the
straight-up undervaluation of real
estate holdings by hundreds of millions
of dollars that what what that quite
simply means is that if you have a
building worth you know twenty million
dollars just the numbers don't really
matter when you transfer that you
straight up claim that the value of that
building is much smaller which reduces
the transfer tax liability and other
taxes that may be associated depending
on whether those property transfers are
happening while the owner is alive or
through their estate once they have
passed away the New York Times also
writes because this is as soon as I read
this the scope and size of this
investigation is so significant
that any realistically credible
investigative entity would absolutely be
in touch with the people who are the
subjects of the story in this case
Donald Trump and his family to get
comment from them and indeed they they
have been they've explained that for
weeks as they've been working on this
story they tried to get statements from
Trump about this they told him they are
working on this
another nothing other than this brief
statement in which Charles harder says
yeah this was Trump's family but Trump
didn't actually do anything it has
nothing to do with Trump period it is
important to point out and this is where
we get to you know we have at least two
justice systems and we also have
probably probably more than that in some
way remember actor Wesley Snipes actor
Wesley Snipes was sentenced to three
years in prison
because of tax charges that were a mere
fraction of what is alleged here against
Donald Trump and his family that's what
I was thinking as I read through this
piece and read through the allegations
that are made here and the other thing
that went through my mind is if the New
York Times was able to figure out this
much stuff and in such detail about
Donald Trump's family's financial
dealings and potential criminality
Muller must know way more than any of us
are accounting for right and that is
something that importantly signals that
the claims that Trump was laundering
Russian money those claims are even more
credible because it appears as though
his entire family has been doing exactly
those types of financial manipulations
through real estate for a decade upon
decade think about that for a moment if
you read Trump's been laundering money
for Russians for years might be true
might be circumstantially supported by
things we know about Donald Trump and
what he and his sons have said but we
now have specific allegation
from the New York Times extraordinarily
well researched allegations that the
Trump family has made it not a habit but
a sort of way of life to use real estate
to move money around in ways that are
evading what the law is surrounding that
money it is significantly more
believable it's almost obvious that of
course Trump was doing money laundering
for the Russians through real estate he
learned how to use real estate to move
money around discreetly or or
surreptitiously from his own father
if this investigation is to be believed
so in the last 24 hours consider what
we've learned in the last 24 - I guess
36 hours we've learned that Brett
Kavanaugh and we'll talk about this
momentarily try to fix his alibi before
Debora Ramirez allit ret Deborah Ramirez
his allegations were made public via The
New Yorker article and potentially
tampered with witnesses we learned that
Donald Trump tried to get stormy Daniels
silenced in advance of that story going
public and now we are learning more and
more about the really undeniable reality
as we've suspected for a long time that
Donald Trump's wealth likely came not
just from that small loan of a million
dollars from his dad but also from
massive criminal level tax fraud which
we are only starting to learn about one
other just little note it's very
interesting to me that the way that this
was supposedly being done according to
the New York Times it involves sort of
more nuanced and sophisticated
accounting and tax stuff and then it
also involves just basic lying about how
billed how much buildings are worth
which is sort of exactly emblematic of
how Donald Trump does things he will lie
and deceive in ways that are more
sophisticated and then he'll straight-up
lie to your face which is exactly what
you're doing when you say my 50 million
dollar building know that this isn't a
good building this thing's only worth 2
million dollars we will absolutely be
following this and again there is now a
new investigation by the New York State
tax department and we'll see what they
ultimately come up with
let's focus in now on lies while under
oath by Brett Kavanaugh we already
talked about how he straight-up didn't
answer many questions during that
hearing where we heard from Brett
Kavanaugh and from his first of many
accusers Christine Blasi Ford we already
talked about the fact that many times
senators started picking apart his
claims that he never blacked out from
drinking to the point where he might not
remember what he did on some nights we
already talked about how his sort of
baseline unhinged nature makes him
fundamentally unfit to be on the Supreme
Court but now I want to focus in on lies
that he told remember senators Jeff
Flake and Chris Coons who called for
this investigation last night said if
any lying is uncovered that's likely the
end of this nomination for Brett
Kavanaugh so this matters okay it's
really important to understand that
Cavanaugh is lying about lots of little
things and that should disqualify him
from being on the court even if it's
each individual lies small or relatively
unimportant it's still against the law
to lie under oath and it still makes him
a liar people who know Cavanaugh are
flooding out saying he lied he lied many
times during the hearing every few hours
there's a new article with people who
know him saying this was a lie that was
a lie Cavanaugh lied so much actually
that it's hard to even know where to
start but let's first start with his
claim about getting into Yale part of
Brett Kavanaugh is unhinged ranting on
Thursday included him saying that he got
into Yale on the basis of his hard work
and that he had no connections to Yale
whatsoever he his exact words that day
were a quote senator you were asking
about college I got into Yale Law School
that's the number one law school in the
country
I had no connections there I got there
by busting my tail in college this is a
lie Brett Kavanaugh was a legacy
admission to Yale meaning he had prior
family members who went to Yale his
grandfather
Everett Edward Cavanaugh went to Yale to
little lie it's one of many but why is
he lying all the time and why do we need
to excuse those lies he claimed that a
Devil's Triangle is a drinking game it's
not other than references added from a
congressional IP address to Wikipedia
after his hearing he knows that it's a
sex act involving two men and a woman
and it's yet another lie he claimed that
the term boof related to flatulence
which it doesn't Cavanaugh knows that it
relates to anal sexual practices he
implied when talking about his drinking
that he was of legal age by saying you
know in 1982 I drank beer 18-year olds
could drink so the seniors could drink
legally that's right the seniors who
were 18 could drink legally he wasn't 18
at the time it's a small lie but it's
yet another lie and then there's kind of
like the bigger narrative lies okay
Cavanaugh's broader story was I just
didn't drink enough to forget stuff I
didn't drink enough to have foggy
memories despite the fact that senators
Booker and Blumenthal and others made a
Klobuchar and others made some pretty
significant progress in showing but that
wasn't true but before and since
Cavanaugh's testimony a bunch of his
classmates have come forward to say he
was frequently stumbling around drunk he
had no rational control over his actions
nor a clear recollection of them he was
asked during the hearing whether he
watched Christine Blasi Ford's testimony
he said no but I plan to watch it later
it was widely reported in multiple media
outlets that he was watching the
testimony the fact that Cavanaugh lied
so much about so many little things is
actually indicative of his they can't
touch me attitude which he shares with
who he shares that attitude with Donald
Trump when you were this willing to
perjure yourself you should not be on
the Supreme Court you really shouldn't
have any government job private
companies are free to decide Pat do they
care about the fact that this guy lies
all the time or not he really shouldn't
have any government job and as I said
before it's not likely that there's
going to be a perjury charge proven here
it's unlikely we're even going to get a
perjury charge but at least one senator
is getting tough on the crime of perjury
by Supreme Court nominees and that's
Bernie Sanders who has now actually
written a letter to Chuck Grassley
who's been running this entire circus of
a confirmation hearing saying the f
I should investigate not only the claims
of the accusers but also whether the guy
lied whether he perjured himself and in
his letter Bernie Sanders said in order
for this FBI investigation regarding
Judge Brett Cavanaugh's nomination to be
complete it is imperative the bureau
must not only look into the accusations
made by dr. Ford Deborah Ramirez and
Julie sweat NIC which they're not doing
by the way it should also examine the
veracity of his testimony before the
Judiciary Committee obviously Bernie
also points out that they should
investigate the claims of all three
women they're not doing that either
Julie sweat Nick attempting to get in
touch with no luck I would make the case
actually that perjury allegations or
maybe more damaging than the sexual
assault allegations not that lying about
what booth means is worse than raping a
woman that's not what I mean but what I
mean is no matter what the FBI comes up
with with regard to sexual assault it's
still gonna be a preponderance of
evidence thing and more than half of
Republicans as I'll tell you later don't
even think sex assault should disqualify
you from the Supreme Court in that sense
if you perjure yourself it's much more
cut and dry Republicans will still say I
don't care put them on the court but I
actually think that you you can make the
case that being a sloppy drunk in
college isn't necessarily disqualifying
from being on the Supreme Court
lying about it constantly as an adult
under oath however should disqualify you
from being on the court it's all just so
hard to prove though like when he claims
that Boo f---ing related to flatulence
not anal sex or The Devil's Triangle
that's a drinking game not a sex act I
mean in his circles he could claim that
that's what those terms meant you can't
just cite urban dictionary and say
there's a discrepancy here or you know I
mean his classmates will come out and
say that this guy drank a lot in college
right he was intoxicated every Friday
and Saturday night him it's it's
unbelievable to think that he could
remember some of that stuff well hey if
he says that he didn't black out how are
you gonna prove otherwise and when it
comes to perjury it does involve whether
he was deliberately saying something
that wasn't true or whether he genuinely
is just mistaken so it's an uphill
battle but I agree with Bernie that the
lying has got to be investigated
here send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show we've got a
great program for you today okay I want
to talk about a sort of bigger picture
story that relates to Brett Cavanaugh
but is actually sort of about Donald
Trump and the Trump Russia investigation
and you might hear that and say I don't
really understand how those things go
together and I'll explain to you how
they go together every single time that
there is another allegation against
Brett Kavanaugh from a sexual assault
accuser or every time that another
Cavanaugh classmate says he lied under
oath about this or he lied under oath
about that every time we figure out
something else that Cavanaugh just
hasn't been upfront about right you hear
from more and more Republican senators
who say you know I really need to think
about whether this is somebody that that
that I can support I immediately wonder
why doesn't Trump just pick somebody
else and the reality is that at any time
Donald Trump could call up Brett
Kavanaugh and say listen I need you to
step aside it's become a circus let me
pick somebody else who isn't going to
have these issues because if it's not
Gavin now Trump can get somebody else
confirmed right that it's not really an
issue of whether Trump can get anyone
confirmed it's a question of whether
Cavanaugh can get confirmed but Trump
hasn't done that Trump has continued to
stay or at least allow the potential
confirmation of Brett Cavanaugh to go
forward
I've up until now basically been of the
mindset that the reason Trump is
continuing with Kavanagh is Trump's
personality Trump doesn't want to be
seen as losing he would see it as a win
to get Brett Kavanaugh on the court and
he would see it as a loss if for
whatever reason he ended up having to
pick somebody else even though either
way you're gonna end up with a
conservative Supreme Court justice on
the court so increasingly I've started
to think it has to be more than just
that it can't just be that Trump simply
wants to win with Kavanagh because this
is taking a long time a lot of political
capital is being expended here what else
could it be and there's an entire other
storyline that could explain Trump's
desire for it
not just any conservatives justice to a
judge to be put on the Supreme Court as
a justice but specifically Kavanagh and
it relates to Trump and Russia and
Robert Muller's investigation and that's
what I want to explain to you today and
see what you think about it if you are a
president who's being investigated for
possible very serious crimes that you've
committed potentially by a special
prosecutor Brett Kavanaugh is exactly
the type of guy that you would want as
the 9th vote on the Supreme Court why
well Cavanaugh has argued not only that
you can't indict a sitting president
they're actually a number of legal
experts who agree with that but that
presidents shouldn't even have to face
criminal prosecution or criminal
investigations while they are presidents
and that presidents don't even have to
follow laws that they deemed to be
unconstitutional there's a major piece
of case law around investigating
presidents which is US v Nixon from 1974
in the past Cavanaugh has questioned the
correctness of that decision many times
on the question of whether a sitting
president can even be subpoenaed to
answer questions again that something
Trump is dealing with right now the
point of view of someone who disagrees
with US v Nixon is very clear if you
think the 1974 Nixon case was decided
incorrectly as Cavanaugh has stated
you're probably going to rule if it came
before the Supreme Court that Donald
Trump cannot be subpoenaed to testify as
part of this investigation
if Trump ultimately wants to fire Robert
Mahler and that decision were to end up
before the Supreme Court if you're a
judge or justice like Cavanaugh and you
think that the 1974 Nixon case was
decided incorrectly you probably rule in
defending Donald Trump's firing of
Robert Muller if it were to take place
now defenders of Cavanaugh
Trump will write into me and they'll say
well yeah he has been critical of that
1974 decision but at other points
Kavanagh has also said that he thinks
the decision was made correctly I think
without a doubt the most recent and
relevant statements that Cavanaugh has
made about that decision are that he
doesn't think it was the right decision
when during his confirmation hearings
Kavanagh was asked by Senator Kamel
Harris whether he had conversations
about the Trump Russia investigation
with anybody at the law firm of mark
Kazu 'its who had been defending
representing Donald Trump in that
investigation he gave non answers that's
another reason Trump may want Cavanaugh
specifically because Cavanaugh may
already have been involved in
discussions about the Trump Russia
Moeller investigation and one can can
even argue actually that Cavanaugh's
lying and unhinged sort of erratic out
of controlled demeanor during last
week's week's hearings might also be
part of why Donald Trump wants him on
the court sort of an audition for it
Trump wants Kavanagh on the court
because quite frankly he wants an angry
erratic dogmatically loyal guy who
believes in almost totally unfettered
presidential power and he wants that
person on the court as soon as humanly
possible so that Trump can get back to
interfering with and getting in the way
of Robert Muller's investigation this
means it's not only incredibly important
to block Kavanagh but we've got to take
over as many seats as possible in
November within those November midterms
which are now just over four weeks away
because not only is this a play to
influence the judiciary of the United
States for decades Kavanagh in his early
50s it's a direct play to continue
interfering with the Trump Russia
investigation which we know has been one
of Donald Trump's top priorities for a
very long time at this point send me
your thoughts could this be why Trump is
sticking with Kavanagh
when pretty clearly at this point it
would probably be easier just to get
somebody else can
firmed make sure you follow the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show follow me on instagram as well at
david pakman behind-the-scenes pictures
of my temporary studio for the week and
much more quick break I will interview
economist Steve Kean coming up next you
know there's something there is
something special about Donald Trump and
this next clip that I'm going to play
demonstrates and I'm obviously saying
special tongue-in-cheek
but take a look at this clip where
cecilia Vega began to ask Donald Trump a
question and he insulted her and in the
very trumpian fashion she's shocked that
I picked her know it's like in a state
of shock I'm not thinking that's okay I
know you're not thinking you never do
I'm sorry no go ahead go ahead
in a tweet this weekend mr. president
you said that it's incorrect to say
you're limiting the scope of the FBI
investigation what does that have to do
with straight well I don't mind
answering the question but you know I'd
like to do the trick do any other
headline in the news which is the
cannibal but I know but how about
talking about trade and then we'll get
to that
ohh-kay here I'm sorry for laughing I'm
sorry for laughing but Donald Trump is
such I can't say it on David's Pat L on
David's program because I know we go
over the radio airwaves but Donald Trump
is an extreme a-hole he is a jerk
to the point of absurdity I mean it's
it's the moment is it's a horrible
moment for America to be sure it is
disgraceful for the President of the
United States to behave in this manner
right to insult this woman for no reason
whatsoever none whatsoever it does show
I really do have to list all the things
wrong with this before I go into what I
was going to say but it really shows his
his disdain for women it shows he has
absolutely no respect for women which is
the same thing but I just have to
reiterate it really shows that Donald
Trump views women through the lens
condescension and this is reflected
through his life particularly with the
accusations against him I mean it makes
total sense that he would want somebody
like Brett Kavanaugh on the Supreme
Court because that is the same type of
personality that he has and so this is a
really disgusting moment for the
President of the United States for this
country but also in Nestle in that is
the fact that Donald Trump is a coward
mind you I still have something else to
say about this at the end but I have to
point this out as well Donald Trump is a
coward
did you see the fierceness in Sicilia
Vegas voice tone demeanor and in her
eyes when she said excuse me
I was like oh it's about to go down like
if you've ever been
if you've ever stepped over the line
with a woman in general because what
I've learned about women which is
absolutely amazing and great is that
they really are not going to bite their
tongue and whereas men you know most of
the time we back down just like Donald
Trump back down look at how he back down
I mean he says this insulting
condescending statement to this woman
and as soon as she checked him she
didn't even have to get him even get
into it all she had to say was excuse me
and he backed down like the coward that
he is I mean this is like this is the
quintessential example of a chauvinist
of a of a bullet there of a chauvinist
pig who tries to insult a woman quickly
realizing that he's not up to he cannot
go toe-to-toe with this individual so I
make a shout-out to cecilia Vega for
like I mean that's that was a read she
read him for filth I'm sorry that's an
African American colloquial that
basically means that she she she told
him off without even having to really
try and it was a beautiful moment for
her in terms of her showing Donald Trump
showing the world that Donald Trump is a
bunch of loud he's not even a barque
right you know all all bark and no bite
he's just a loud mouth fouled
individual with no respect for anyone
else but at the core of him he's a
coward now what I wanted to say at the
beginning but I had to really outline
all the things that was wrong with this
is that Donald Trump is such he's a
clown he's a jerk he's a joke and you
know what for people who who like jerks
and in your own head I want you to
substitute jerk for another word because
we're on radio but but for people who
like that they probably think that this
was the funniest thing that they ever
saw yesterday and they are applauding
him now part of me I am a jerk I'm
personally I you know I too suffer from
a Hillary and so I laughed at this
segment and then I had a pause and come
you know and think about it and see
everything that was wrong with it so
thankfully I have the ability to
transcend my Jirka tude I'm an idiot and
amongst other things but the point is
this is that there's an entire group of
people out there who will see this as a
pro they they will see this as something
redeeming in Donald Trump they love this
about Donald Trump and isn't that just
isn't it so indicative of the times in
which we live where we can see something
and we can whether we initially see how
repugnant it is or like me it takes a
moment for you to compose yourself and
really and analyze it from a decent
human being perspective either/or you
know I got to include myself in a good
group obviously but there's an entire
group of us who can see this and see the
problem with it whereas you have in
another segment of a society whose seat
of American of the voting electorate
more specifically who look at this and
they see nothing wrong in fact they see
this is the exact reason why they voted
for Donald Trump and they applaud him
and they want more of this this this is
the dichotomy of America this is where
what we've broken down into and that is
a problem that's brewing underneath the
surface of America that we're now
getting to a fever pitch and we really
have to see where these two facts
actually go